- You know, I really--
I hate to waste your time,
but I'm really not looking to do
more advertising right now.
- Mm-hmm.
- Yeah, no.
- Okay? I'm so sorry.
- Yeah, no worries.
I hear that.
- Okay, that gives me
a certain amount of relief.
- Definitely hear that.
- Thank you.
- How you feeling?
- I'm in the sweet spot,
not too drunk,
not too sober.
- Me, too, baby.
Let's go in for the kill.
- You got it, pal.
- Jack, you're known
all over town as the guy
with a dick in his mouth.
- Well...it's not just dicks.
- No, it's not.
- It's not.
- I've seen boobs.
- Yes.
- I've seen poop.
- I have too.
- I've seen a butt
pooping boobs.
- Yup, yup.
- I've seen Andre the Giant.
- I've seen that.
Don't get it, but I've seen it.
- And let's not forget
about the speech bubbles.
- Yup, yup.
- "I'm hungry for turds."
- That's right by my church.
- "I'm thirsty for dongs."
- Mm-hmm.
- "Feed me wieners."
- Do you think
it's just one guy?
- No, Jack.
- But we at Cramblin-Duvet
can put an end
to all that nonsense
by rebranding you
in a television commercial.
- To be honest, the billboards
don't really bother me, okay?
I actually--I think
they're kind of funny.
You know what I mean?
Young man, I know
what you're doing.
You're busted.
Yeah, that's great.
You're using
forced perspective
to make it look like
I'm fellating that bread stick.
Grow up. Grow up.
Oh, and there we go.
Dinner roll balls.
Dinner roll balls,
really original.
You know what?
I am tired of this.
Sign me up.
Let's do this.
- All right.
- Oh, man, okay.
- Champagne...of beers.
- You've already had
five drinks each.
- Just bring them!
- What's your problem, man?
- Oh, I am really excited
right now.
This feels good.
- It's gonna be great, Jack.
- Whoo!
[laughs]